[Music]
many more people should be leaving their
jobs go do your work thing you're gonna
die is it your mind is it society is it
your Park why are you not willing to
take one step backwards for a step for
the rest of your life how many people by
show of hands work in a job and are
desperate for their side hustle to
become their career just raise your
hands
[Music]
so many of you created golden handcuffs
for yourself that aren't a letting you
leave your job because you need to make
a hundred thirty thousand a year now
because you wanted seven hundred more
square feet in your apartment
where you wanted a BMW instead of a
Toyota
something I'd realize that really kind
of caught me off guard
is how many people spend more money on
[ __ ] than they can afford the fact that
30 [ __ ] 5% of this audience wants
their side hustle to be their careers
but the reason they can't is because
they can't quit their job because they
need their job to pay for dumb [ __ ] to
impress people they [ __ ] hate and so
you're not happy because you wanted two
or three things that mean absolutely
nothing why you're not you not willing
to take one step backwards for a step
for the rest of your life the amount of
people that have emailed me in the last
six months because I've been on this
rant lately of trying to get people to
move back in with their parents at 30
and 40 you're worried about if you move
back in with your parents or if you're
not married for the job at 31 you are
not willing to take a step backwards a
step backwards which then affords you
the ability to quit your [ __ ] job or
stop doing your [ __ ] startup and do
something else you love or you think you
can be good at like who the hell's
permission are you looking for to do
your thing like who is this person is it
your mom is it society is it your
partner is that the people that are
commenting in your social media is it
something that happened to you when you
were nine if you're pessimistic moms I'm
gonna see I told you you could never do
it if you can't get over that and you're
[ __ ] stuck
[Music]
[Applause]
go do your thing you're gonna die it's
going to end something bad is gonna
happen something great is gonna happen
but most of all nothing's gonna happen
unless you do something please stop
looking for Commission please go do that
thing you wanted to do ask that person
out start that company quit that [ __ ]
[ __ ] job you could always get
another [ __ ] job how are you not
willing to take a step backwards because
of other people's opinions and willing
to ruin the next 47 years of your life
take a [ __ ] step backwards to take a
step forward for the rest of your life
[Music]